(whooshing)
- [Announcer] This UCSD-TV
program is presented
by University of California Television.
Like what you learn?
Visit our website or follow
us on Facebook and Twitter
to keep up with the latest programs.
(playful piano music)
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape.
Bipedal, naked, large brain.
Long the master of
fire, tools and language
but still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable,
yet filled with optimism.
We grow up slowly.
We hand down knowledge.
We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future
from our shared understanding of the past.
CARTA brings together experts
from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who
we are and how we got here.
An exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
(dramatic piano music)
(light whooshing)
(ambient shimmering)
- That's kind of a
gruesome picture, isn't it?
But I like to imagine Darwin
in the dissecting room,
actually helping us all out.
So this is a lecture that's
an experiment for me.
It's shifting the focus.
All of my previous lectures
about evolution and medicine
have been about traits, things like height
and pneumonia and cancer and all the rest.
Today, I'm gonna shift
gears and try to apply
the things we've learned
about how to analyze
why traits are vulnerable
to disease, and ask instead
why genes that cause disease
persist in the genome,
despite the actions of natural selection.
Evolutionary medicine,
just to be very clear,
is not a specialized method of practice.
There's nothing alternative
about it whatsoever.
It's simply applying the
well-established basic principles
from evolutionary biology to
medicine and public health
and trying to use them
to improve human health.
So the central question
I've been preoccupied by is
why do bodies have traits
that make them vulnerable to disease?
Completely different from
the usual medical research question.
Most medical research is about
why people are different.
Our interest is instead
about why we are all the same
in ways that are kind of like
the gas tank on the Pinto.
There are things about our bodies,
from our backs to our appendices.
Well, we'll get to that in a moment.
The first half of medical school,
you must react with awe if
you're paying attention at all.
The Loop of Henle in the
kidney, no details now,
but, oh, my gosh, if you're not astounded,
you're not paying attention.
Everybody recognizes
how great the heart is
and the valves in the right
place at the right time,
and the pump does not need
to be oiled every few months.
The eye is miraculous in the
fact of its astounding function
although it's actually not well-designed.
The human hand is almost equally good
in terms of all of those
muscles and tendons and joints
working in tandem to allow
us to do amazing things.
The clotting mechanism had
better work well or else,
and then the part of
biology that I thought
was absolutely ridiculous and stupid
and at least made me mad
when I was a medical student,
and now I find fascinating
because I've taken
an evolutionary viewpoint, is biochemistry
and intermediary metabolism.
(audience laughing)
For any students in the
audience, I assure you,
don't pay attention to your professors.
Go to evolutionary
thinking about these things
and it will make sense.
That's the first half of medical school.
Second half, you get into the
clinic and what do you see?
Somebody goofed.
You start off with wisdom teeth, why?
You go further to the appendix, whoa!
You go further to the place in your arm
that always breaks when you fall forward?
Why isn't it bigger?
The coronary arteries,
couldn't they just be
a little bit wider, please?
And as for that birth
canal, why not just have
a zipper in the front instead of...
(audience laughing)
And then there's the spine,
as I mentioned before.
The body could be so much better
in so many different ways.
These are traits, not genes, just traits,
and the old answer about
why natural selection
didn't do a better job is, well,
it's a random process
and it's not that strong.
That is absolutely one
important contribution
to why bodies aren't
better, but it's only one,
and a foundation for
evolutionary thinking in medicine
has been to analyze
every kind of vulnerability of a trait
in terms of six possible
different evolutionary reasons
why we're vulnerable.
I'm going to list them very quickly.
I've given many, many lectures about these
applying to traits, they're on
the web if you're interested.
Today, I'm gonna zip through
them and apply them to genes.
One is natural selection just can't do it.
Two is we're living in an environment
very different from the
environment in which we evolved.
Three is that pathogens,
bacteria and viruses
evolve faster than we do.
Four is trade-offs;
nothing can be perfect.
Everything can be adjusted
in ways that are better
but at the cost of making
something else worse.
Five, and this is a deep one,
natural selection does not
shape any organism for health
or longevity or happiness or cooperation.
It shapes all of them for maximizing
their ability to transmit their genes.
Very disturbing idea.
The last is useful defenses
that seem like diseases,
such as fever, pain, nausea,
vomiting, cough and all the rest.
Now, I'm gonna shift though, my usual talk
and give up on talking about
traits, and ask about genes,
the focus of so much modern
medical research, and ask,
why do genes that increase
risk of disease persist?
And the first thing I recognized
as I started down this path
is that we don't need to just
talk about the usual foci
of medical research,
which are the myriad kinds
of specific variations in genes
that make us vulnerable to disease.
We also need to talk about genes
that we all share, that are fixed,
fixed means we all have it,
that make us vulnerable to disease.
This led me to just say
there's four different kinds
of genes we should be thinking about.
First are the regular
ones, widespread variation,
all the regular genetic studies.
Two, variation between populations.
DARC is a gene that almost
everyone in Africa has
because it protects against vivax malaria.
Hardly anyone living in
northern climates has this gene.
Fixed or missing genes
for everybody recently.
Recently, the past few million years.
The one that Ajit Varki
studies, Neu5Gc and GLO,
more about those in just a moment.
The fourth category is
genes that we all have,
such as genes that make bilirubin,
and genes that make dopamine,
all of which make us
vulnerable to disease.
So, a big shift in thinking
here, not just variations
among individuals and
their different genes,
but genes that we all have
that make us vulnerable to disease.
The first reason, limits of selection.
Selection can't do things,
and the biggest limit to
selection is mutations happen.
About 60 to 130 per
individual per generation,
and a deep question for another time is
how on earth the genome
can fail to melt down
given the difficulty of
getting rid of each of those,
but they are all gradually
selected out by natural selection,
except that natural selection's
by no means all powerful.
There's something that
geneticists call drift,
which is really referring
to random factors
that make genes become more or less common
just by luck of the draw,
not because of anything pushing them
to higher or lower frequencies.
This can result in good genes being lost
and good genes becoming more common.
Here is the biggest question that faces us
in medical genetics today.
We all thought, just about 15 years ago,
that the highly heritable diseases,
such as schizophrenia,
autism, bipolar disease,
and things like diabetes and all the rest,
that they were highly heritable,
we know their variation in these diseases
is caused by genetic variations,
so we should be able to find the genes
and fix these diseases.
This has been one of the greatest
disappointments in modern medicine.
We're making some progress, but,
it was a huge disappointment.
This is a graph done by
one of my former students
in this college looking at
genes for schizophrenia.
I say genes, what I really mean,
for the technically inclined, is alleles.
That is, different variations
that influence risk of
something like schizophrenia.
These are ones that are
relatively uncommon,
and they have relatively large effects.
Increase in the risk of schizophrenia
by as much as five to 10 times,
but they're very, very rare.
These re alleles that
are relatively common,
and their effect on schizophrenia
is really quite tiny.
They increase the risk by 1% or 2% or 3%.
Notice that they all
fall on the same line.
Notice next that there
are no genes over there.
There are no effects.
There are no common genes of large effect.
What happened to them?
Natural selection eliminated
them is the main hypothesis.
But, more important here,
all of these genes have the exact same
proportion of variants explained,
and the data proportion
of variants is 0.04%,
which is a teensy, teensy,
teensy amount of explanation.
This has been terribly frustrating.
A gene that causes less than 5% of 5%
is not gonna get you very far in terms of
explaining these diseases.
Sickle Cell Disease has been the exemplar
for evolutionary medicine,
but I'd like to suggest to
you, it's a very poor exemplar.
It's interesting, because of the mechanism
that maintains the
frequency of the alleles
that cause Sickle Cell Disease.
It was first discovered, actually, in part
by colleagues of mine at Michigan,
Jim Neil and his colleagues,
and they pointed out that
when they went to Africa and looked at
the distribution of malaria
and the distribution
of Sickle Cell Disease,
it was about the same.
And, then they thought about it
more deeply in a genetic way,
and recognized something that's called
balancing selection, this maintains
the frequency of the alleles
that cause Sickle Cell Disease.
You have to have two of them
to get the Sickle Cell Disease
at a certain frequency.
If you have two regular hemoglobin copies,
you're vulnerable to Malaria,
but you don't get Sickle Cell Disease.
If you have two of the Sickle
Cell kinds of hemoglobin,
you get severe disease, often dying young,
and usually not being able to reproduce.
But, if you have one of each,
and you're living in Africa
where the malaria is common,
or around the Mediterranean,
where it's common,
it's not just Africa,
you get some malaria protection,
and the anemia is not too severe.
These people do better in terms of
having more offspring than these or these,
and this means that, so long
as that gene isn't too common,
if it gets too common then a lot of people
get two copies, and it's terrible.
If it's really rare, no
benefit, but middle range.
Fascinating example, but
again, it's not a great example
because what natural selection
does when these kind of things happen
is find some other solution.
This has only been going
on for 10 to 20,000 years,
and we don't have very many other examples
of balancing selection.
I say this because so
many of my colleagues,
especially in psychiatry,
are constantly making up
stories about possible traits,
like schizophrenia for instance,
resulting from heterozygote advantage
or balancing selection.
Usually, not much evidence for that
except for other kinds
of hemoglobinopathies
to protect against malaria.
There are a few others, but
it's not a common explanation,
shouldn't be the exemplar.
Something that should be, though,
is something like dopamine.
You probably are all aware that
dopamine in the substantia
nigra in the brain,
in basal ganglia, if you
don't have enough of it,
and your neurons are dying off,
you get Parkinson's Disease.
It's common.
Why are we vulnerable
to Parkinson's Disease?
Well, turns out that it's inherent
to the nature of the dopamine molecule.
When it's metabolized,
the dopamine molecule
makes hydrogen peroxide
and other oxygen radicals.
These things, whenever they
glom onto a piece of
tissue, fry it, essentially.
Dopamine is an inherently toxic molecule,
and we're not gonna be able to replace it,
because it's been used to regulate
motivation systems for
about a billion years, now.
No chance of changing that,
but it's also inherently dangerous.
There are built in protection mechanisms
in those nerves to protect them
against the effects of dopamine,
and if those aren't working quite right
for one reason or another,
people get Parkinson's Disease.
Second explanation, mismatch
with the environment.
We used to think that common diseases
were caused by common genes,
and we would find them.
But, that turned out not to be the case.
Hardly any common diseases are caused by
common genes that are large effects.
Most disease genes that have large effects
are what George Williams
and I have called quirks.
Quirks are not defective,
they're genes that have bad effects
only in modern environments.
This leads to the paradoxical finding that
most highly heritable diseases
are caused by the environment.
Doesn't that sound odd?
Quirks, harmless in a natural environment,
cause disease in novel environment,
Ken Weiss, a geneticist, says
a widespread dispersion of
these common risk alleles,
they're benign, the proofs are benign,
so if they're associated with disease,
this mans that they're interacting
with modern environments
to causing disease,
pointing the finger to the environment.
So next time the New York Times says,
"We found a gene for atherosclerosis,"
it's probably a gene
that didn't do much harm
back in the environments with the sort
that Mike Gurven was studying.
It's a gene that interacts with Big Macs
to cause heart attacks.
Nearsightedness, whether
you're nearsighted or not
depends almost entirely on your genes.
So why didn't natural
selection get rid of them?
Answer, hardly anyone is
nearsighted in ancestral environments.
Something about modern
environments boosts the rate
so that everybody that has
those genes gets nearsighted.
Three candidates for that,
one is doing close work,
two is high doses of sugar,
three, low levels of light
because of living indoors.
Yet, to discover exactly what this is,
we could eventually cure
or prevent nearsightedness
if we could find the answer.
Scurvy, our ancestors didn't have scurvy
because they made their own,
ancestors back a few million years,
they made their own Vitamin C.
But, we lost the ability
to make Vitamin C,
and we lost it right about here.
All the monkeys, marmosets, and humans,
and gorillas, we can't make it.
Lemurs and others can.
Why did that ability get lost?
One hypothesis has been
that it's just because
we had so much fruit in
our diet, it didn't matter.
That's a perfectly plausible one,
but other people have suggested that
changes in this particular enzyme
increase our ability to store fats.
Very interesting to try
to answer that question.
Third reason is infection.
Pathogens evolve faster than we do.
It's too bad, and it's amazing
that we can ever, ever outrun them.
Therefore, it is very strong selection
to survive whatever kinds of pathogens
and infections are around,
but whenever you see a mutation
that gets selected so
strongly to prevent infection,
you should look very carefully to see if
there might be bad side
effects to that gene.
Turns out that there's lots
of evidence about this.
A nice recent paper goes
through many of them,
shows pretty convincingly
that each epidemic shapes
quite dramatic changes
in allele frequencies,
and furthermore, it points out that CCR5,
you get HIV protection if you
have this particular mutation,
but you're more vulnerable to West Nile.
If you have an O blood type,
you get protection against malaria,
but you're more vulnerable to cholera.
We need to think about
good genes and bad genes.
We need to be thinking about variations
that have costs and benefits.
Trade-offs, nothing in
the body is perfect.
Everything is a trade-off.
My favorite example is bilirubin.
Why make bilirubin?
It's toxic, it turns you yellow.
Turns out, it's wonderful at stopping
reactive oxygen species
from burning up your tissues.
And people who have a disease
causing high bilirubin levels
have heart attacks at
half the rate of others.
Very important for practical terms
in a neonatal nursery,
because they're routinely put under lights
for even mild increases of bilirubin,
even though that bilirubin decreases
the number of reactionary
oxygen species in their bodies.
Genes for aging, George
Williams pointed out
a new explanation that is,
they might have benefits in childhood,
when selection is strong,
and costs only later in life.
The so-called Antagonistic
Pleiotropy Theory.
If, in fact, we could eliminate aging,
and the mortality rate stayed the same
throughout life as it is at age 20,
most of us would live to
about age 800 to 1000.
Amyloid Beta is the bad guy for
causing Alzheimer's Disease,
but has demonstrated recently
that in fact, it's potent antimicrobial.
Every single one of these genes
seems like it's just a bad actor,
but it's there for a reason.
Not all are, we shouldn't assume it,
but we should consider the possibilities.
And Ajit Varki's work, he's shown that
all human are missing a gene that our
primate ancestors all had,
that is one for Neu5Gc,
and it turns out that two
or three million years ago we lost it,
but we keep eating other
foods that have that in it,
and it may well be that
causes inflammatory reactions,
which might be responsible for the
high burden of inflammatory
disease in humans.
It might be that the reason that happened
was to help us avoid the kind of malaria
that influences chimpanzees
because that molecule is what
the malaria pathogen uses
to get into blood cells.
Change can increase
reproduction in harm health,
Apo E4 increases
progesterone in reproduction,
even though it causes heart
attacks and Alzheimer's Disease.
Even the BRCA gene, causing breast cancer,
has been said to increase
number of offspring.
And finally, defenses, such as
pain, fever, and all the rest
are useful but at a high cost.
Wrapping up, why do disease genes persist?
The same six categories
that prove so useful
in trying to understand why certain traits
are vulnerable to causing disease
helps us understand genetic variations
and genetic uniformities in ways
that make us vulnerable to disease.
Constraints leave us with mutations
heterozygote advantage vulnerabilities.
Mismatched results in quirks
that were harmless now causing disease.
Trade-offs come with benefits, but costs.
Pathogens create arm races.
Reproduction sometimes
shapes changes in genes
that increase reproduction
at a cost to health,
and defenses are dangerous and costly.
Again, going back to four
different kinds of genes,
variations among individuals,
variations among human subgroups,
recent changes that we all have,
such as losing the ability
to synthesize Vitamin C,
and then other things like dopamine,
that we all have had for a very long time.
We need to be thinking about all these
different kinds of genes and their
ways in which they make us
more vulnerable to disease.
This exercise of writing
this lecture was fun for me,
because it came out with surprising
conclusions I hadn't anticipated.
First, there's a very high proportion
of disease vulnerability
genes that are shaped by
benefits of protecting against infection.
And, two, they persist
because of selection for
infection increase in reproduction
and extending the lifespan.
Those of you who are interested,
we now do have a scientific society,
Evolutionary Medicine, it's called
The International Society for
Evolution Medicine and Public Health.
We have a meeting in Europe
that you'd be welcome to go.
EvMedEd is a resource, and EvMedReview.com
offers news for the field,
including right now a meeting that's open
for anyone who wants to attend,
November 10th in Berlin,
and information about jobs at ASU.
Thanks very much.
(dramatic piano music)
- As humans, we often ponder
the pleasures of life.
Things like good food,
a drink with friends
after a long week of work,
falling in love, that's
a great thing in life,
spending time with family.
These are all undoubtedly great things
that we enjoy in our lives.
I'd also argue that sleep is
one of those great things in our lives.
There's nothing better than sleep
when you're truly tired,
and the feeling of climbing into bed,
pulling up the covers,
putting your head down and
falling asleep is pure bliss.
And we see this in cases of
extreme sleep deprivation.
(audience laughing)
For example, here's a
picture of Peter Tripp.
He was a DJ in New York in the 1950s,
and as a publicity and fundraising stunt,
he tried to stay awake
for as long as he could.
He managed to stay awake
for over eight days,
which is pretty remarkable,
on the air the entire time,
what's even more remarkable to me is that
others came along and
actually beat his record.
I can't imagine why anyone
would wanna do this.
But, on a less extreme scale,
I bet that most everyone in this room
follows the same pattern that I do.
And, that is, we sleep too
little during the week,
and then we catch up on
sleep on the weekend.
And so, I bring up these
examples to illustrate
the love/hate relationship that
we seem to have with sleep.
On the one hand, we love sleep,
and people often say, "I love sleep."
But, on the other hand,
we always have something
better to do than sleep, isn't that right?
You know, sleep is seen as
something that we can do without,
or that we would like to do without,
and certainly, we cut
into it very commonly,
and so, just like we hear
people say, "I love sleep,"
we also hear them say,
"I wish I could function on less sleep."
Now, today, I wanna present some findings
from my lab over the last couple of years
that suggest that this
love/hate relationship
is not a new phenomenon.
It's not a new phenomenon
associated with television,
or social media, or artificial lighting,
or all the other kinds of
evils you might think of
if you're in sleep
medicine or sleep biology.
Instead, our findings are suggesting that
natural selection has
been whittling away sleep
along the human lineage
probably for millions of years.
We also think that this
might have implications
for understanding some
aspects of human health.
So, I wanna start with a
little bit of background.
First of all, what is sleep?
Sleep is a reversible state of rest.
So, it's not like a coma,
it can be easily reversed, sleep can.
It involves reduced awareness,
and responsiveness to surroundings.
It involves a rebound effect.
I just talked about that
with our catch-up sleep
that many of us are going to have tonight
after this long week of work,
and travel, and everything else.
You have to compensate for lost sleep.
Very importantly, sleep is not one thing.
It's actually two different things.
Sleep, when you're not awake,
you're actually in two different states.
You're in non-REM sleep, or in REM sleep,
rapid eye movement sleep,
and REM sleep is, of course, when
the most visual dreaming occurs.
A sleep biologist can differentiate
these two stages based on EEG.
Now, I wanna just walk you through
what would be considered an ideal
or normal night's sleep.
This is showing and eight hour time period
from about 11 p.m. until roughly 7 a.m.,
so an eight hour block
of consolidated sleep.
And, ideally, you would fall
into the deeper stages
of non-REM sleep first,
you'd spend some time in non-REM sleep,
and then you'd actually arouse
out of non-REM and go into REM.
It's a different stage,
it's not just a deeper
stage of non-REM sleep.
That cycle, then, continues
throughout the night,
you go into a second bout
now of non-REM sleep,
into deep slow-wave sleep, and
you come out into REM sleep.
Now, periodically, throughout the night,
you would also awaken.
I wanna really focus
on one question today.
How does human sleep differ
from the sleep we see in other primates?
I wanna be a little more
provocative, and ask,
are humans evolutionary outliers
in terms of the kinds
of sleep that we have,
in terms of the
characteristics of our sleep?
And so, of course we think
in evolutionary anthropology
a lot about how humans are
different from other primates.
Often, those are questions
about discreet traits,
qualitative traits, bipedalism,
how we use tools, or whether we use tools,
or whether we have a theory of mind.
Here, I'm interested in
a quantitative trait,
the characteristics of sleep.
And so, I need to first define
what I mean by an evolutionary outlier.
This is a trait that's more
extreme than one would predict
based on the modeling of trait evolution
on a phylogeny, on an evolutionary tree.
So, based on what we
know about the various
socio-ecological factors that
influence sleep in primates
as well as the phylogeny
and where we fall in that phylogeny,
we can predict sleep
characteristics in humans.
So, for example, we know that
predation risk across mammals
will tend to reduce sleep times.
If animals do not have safe
place to sleep, they sleep less.
And so we can use that
knowledge across mammals
to actually predict what
human sleep would look like.
And then, of course, once
we have a good prediction
and some confidence intervals on it,
we could ask, "Where
does our observe value
"of human sleep fall compared
to what is predicted?"
If it falls outside that distribution,
we would be an outlier.
We're different from
what you would predict
based on what's known about
sleep in other primates.
And so we use a method that's
been developed in my lab
called phylogenetic prediction
where we use a statistical
model in phylogeny to predict
the phenotype in a particular
species, in this case, humans.
We basically have a bunch
of different variables
that can go into this,
and we estimate these
parameters in the model,
and we also incorporate
evolutionary history.
We implement this, we make
estimates of this model
using a Bayesian approach that produces
a posterior probability
distribution of predictions.
So this is what you might
see in this kind of a case.
We use this approach and we come up with
a posterior probability distribution
of predictions, as you see here.
Then the question, of course,
is where do humans fall?
Are we above this distribution?
Is our observe sleep time
above this distribution?
We would be a positive outlier.
Or, we could be a negative outlier,
the observed value falls
below this distribution.
Or, we can be about what you
would expect if we were a typical primate.
So, the critical question in
all of this, of course, is
what value do we put on this distribution?
So, what is the duration of human sleep?
What would be a good estimate
of the duration of human sleep?
Well, here, I'm gonna use
a value of seven hours,
and I think that's a fairly
conservative estimate based on
several different lines of evidence.
Some of this evidence
is from our own work,
studying a traditional
population agriculturalist,
who live in Madagascar,
and they're a population
without access to electricity.
And in this population,
I'll talk about this
a little bit later in my talk,
we find that people sleep, on
average, 6 1/2 hours a night.
We've also studied the
Hadza hunter-gatherers,
There we find that the average sleep time
is 6.2 hours per night.
Likewise, a recent study of
three hunter-gather groups
found that the average sleep time
across those three groups
was 6.5 hours, pretty short.
These guys don't have TV, right?
They don't have all the
things that we have,
the social media and
the artificial lighting,
and they're actually
sleeping a little bit less.
Another study of a non-electric population
also gives seven hours,
or we can look at western populations
and it's about seven hours
in a recent meta-analysis.
And so, we think that this is
a conservative estimate of
typical human sleep, seven hours.
Okay, so here's a picture
of a Hadza man sleeping
with his fire, some weapons next to him,
on the ground, which is different
from most other primates.
And I just wanna share with you
the three things that we've
found from our analyses.
First of all, humans sleep
less than would be predicted.
So we're a negative outlier.
We spend a greater proportion
of time in REM sleep,
that rapid eye movement sleep,
and we are very flexible in our sleep,
more flexible than would be predicted.
Alright, so, let me walk
you through the evidence
for each of these three points.
First of all, here's the
distribution of sleep times
for primates where we have data.
We have a pretty good number
of species now studied for their sleep,
and what you see is that humans
are the shortest sleeping
of all the primates.
Now, again, we wanna control for phylogeny
and for these other ecological variables
and so we've used this
phylogenetic prediction
approach that I talked about.
Here's our equation that we're using
to predict sleep duration in humans,
and here's our posterior probability
distribution of those predictions.
What you can see is
that the observed value
falls below this distribution.
We are a negative outlier.
In fact, the mean predicted
sleep duration for humans
is 10.3 hours from this analysis,
and we're clearly different from that.
Here's the second result
involving REM sleep.
Humans, again, have the highest percentage
of REM sleep of all the primates.
Now again, we wanted to
use this outlier approach,
this phylogenetic prediction approach,
ancestral so again, here's our equation
relating REM sleep to activity period,
body mass, brain size, diet,
inter-birth interval
group size and phylogeny,
and you can see the posterior
distribution in this case,
and here's the observed value.
So, here, we're a positive outlier.
We know that this is achieved
via higher than expected REM sleep,
so if we just look at
the total amount of REM,
we're looking here at
the percentage of REM,
but the total REM, we have
higher than expected REM
and less than expected non-REM.
It looks like both of these are shifted.
Okay, then, the final set of
results I wanna share with you
involves a hypothesis that
we came up with based on
the ethnographic literature,
based on experimental studies,
and based on the historical record.
And that is that natural
human sleep is more flexible
than we usually appreciate.
Let me just walk you through some of the
findings that were already out there
before we came into the sphere.
Here's an example form the
ethnographic literature.
A work by Dan Everett on the Piraha
South American hunter-gatherers,
where he reports that
the Piraha take naps,
15 minutes to two hours at the extreme
during the day and night.
There's loud talking in
the village all night long.
Consequently it's very difficult
for outsiders to sleep
well among the Piraha.
In a more, sort of review article
of all of this ethnographic
literature on sleep patterns,
Carol Worthman notes that human nights
are filled with activity and significance
and nowhere do people typically sleep
from evening until dawn.
In terms of the historical record,
some of you might be familiar
with Roger Ekirch's work
in which he looked through
the historical record
in multiple cultures
in Europe over the past
couple of thousand years,
and found evidence in much
of the written record there
for references to a first
sleep and a second sleep
with a period of night
time activity in between.
So, he found evidence for what
would be called segmented sleep.
And, likewise, in experimental studies,
for example, Tom Ware's studies,
when he put humans into
a long night condition,
so a 14 hour condition where people were
not allowed to have access to lighting,
they shifted into a
biphasic sleep condition.
So, again, segmented sleep.
'Course, other primates also
show night time activity,
but my colleagues and I in my lab
have hypothesized that humans
are more extreme than other primates.
Well, unfortunately, we don't
have data on other primates,
but we can look at how flexible sleep is
among people living in
traditional populations.
So, as I mentioned, we've
been doing in the Hadza.
This is work led by a post-doc
in my lab, David Samson.
We've been doing work in the
Hadza using actigraphy devices
that are just watches, basically,
that measure activity levels,
and from that, with algorithms
we can make inferences about sleep.
Also, in the Malagasy population,
the agriculturists, we've
been using actigraphy,
but also EEG, so we actually have
the gold-standard measure of sleep
in one of these two populations.
And, I just wanna share with you
some of the things that we find.
This is a big table,
but let me focus on two
elements in it.
This is total sleep duration,
in the Madagascar population,
6.5 hours, as I mentioned previously,
compared to seven in a
typical western population,
in this case, in the USA,
using the same techniques.
Likewise, the sleep fragmentation metrics
are much higher in the
Malagasy population,
and sleep efficiency is much lower.
So, they're up a lot
more during the night.
Likewise, we found some
evidence for segmented sleep,
the same kind of segmented sleep
that Roger Ekirch has documented
in European historical record.
So, this is showing a
functional linear modeling
of circadian patterns among
the individuals in our sample.
This is the night time
hours in this population.
What we find is a significant
bump up in activity,
especially in men, just after midnight,
for a substantial amount of time, in fact.
This is at the time when there's over
12 hours of darkness in this
population, so, their winter.
And, as well, we find in
the Hadza hunter-gatherers,
that once they go to
sleep, there can often be
long periods of wakefulness,
and quite fragmented sleep,
as you can see from some of these plots,
where the dark lines are
indicating sleep time,
with the first one being
the inferred sleep onset,
and then lots of activity at night.
Okay, so I wanna wrap
up with three questions,
very quickly go through three questions.
First of all, why are
humans such short sleepers?
What is going on with this?
Based on this, should we
be short sleepers today?
Is this giving us some reason to think
that maybe we don't
need all of this sleep?
And then, finally, does the
evolution of short sleep
potentially affect health?
Okay, so why are humans
such short sleepers?
Our answer to that is
that, just like today,
throughout human evolution, our ancestors
have had better things to do than sleep.
Some of the potential selective forces
that might be at play to
shorten sleep along our lineage,
is that we sleep on the ground,
and we know from other
species, other primates,
there's greater predation
risk on the ground.
If you are experiencing
greater predation risk,
that should select for less sleep.
As well, being on the ground
may expose individuals
to greater inter and inter-group conflict,
where it would be easier
for a con-specific,
another member of homo-sapiens,
to attack at night
because of this terrestrial sleep.
But, as well, sleep comes
with opportunity costs,
and one of those involves
social interaction.
When you're sleeping,
you're not socializing,
and we know how important
socializing is for humans.
In particular, it's important
in the context of social learning.
From the awake time to acquire
and transmit new skills and knowledge.
So, we think that many of things
that have made humans so successful
have also favored less sleep.
Now, as well, the higher
percentage of REM sleep
may relate to this last
issue because it's thought
that REM sleep also plays a role
in consolidation of memories and
simulating various kinds of
threats and problem solving.
So, do these results suggest
that we should sleep less?
Should we be considering a
paleo-sleep plan of some kind?
I think our findings and
those of others are suggesting
that a paleo-sleep plan would involve
very short and fragmented sleep,
very broodish in another way.
And I think we can turn
to evolutionary medicine
to help us think about this issue.
A central tenet of evolutionary medicine,
as we've heard in the previous talks,
is that natural selection operates
on reproductive success, not on health.
In fact, short, fragmented
sleep is associated
with many poor health outcomes.
Those include cardiovascular disease,
higher rates of cardiovascular disease,
metabolic dysfunction of various sorts,
involving diabetes, for
example, and cancer.
So there are serious problems with having
a short, fragmented sleep.
Yet, many of these problems
would actually occur
likely later in life, post reproduction
in the selection shadows.
And so, perhaps, we need to think about
whether reproductive success
is more relevant to us today,
or health and longevity.
If reproductive success is important,
maybe a paleo-sleep plan is a good one,
but I bet that most people in this room
are more concerned about
health and longevity,
in which case this is probably a bad idea.
In fact, I would suggest that humans today
are having the best
sleep that we've ever had
in our evolutionary history.
So you could imagine that this gentleman's
having a much better sleep on average
than this individual is
going to have tonight.
And there are many reasons to enjoy this,
for those health benefits
I just mentioned,
as well as for better cognitive function,
better immune function, et cetera.
Does evolution help us understand
modern sleep and sleep disorders?
Of course, many people do not get to
experience this kind of nice,
relaxing sleep, consolidated sleep.
For example, many people,
about 10% of the U.S. population,
has some kind of insomnia,
and based on our findings,
I guess one question that arises is
should we really expect to sleep
through the night, every night?
That doesn't look like
it's really been a part
of our evolutionary history.
That seems to me a modern
phenomenon that we strive for.
And so, perhaps
middle-of-the-night insomnia
is not so unexpected,
especially for those of us
that may have ancestors who had
that kind of segmented sleep pattern.
As well, you could
imagine that individuals
who experience threats of various kinds
would have an adaptive
response to not sleep,
and of course, in modern society,
many people do experience these threats.
People living in inner city
environments, for example,
or people in a relationship where
there might be domestic violence.
As well, there's societal
threats, such as racism.
Many people are now showing
that these kind of threats
affect people's sleep,
leading to sleep disparities,
and they're even linking that up to
some of the other health
disparities that are known,
for example, among different
racial groups in the U.S.
And so, finally, does the
evolution of short sleep
help us to understand disease?
Is there a case of that?
Recently, Randy Nesse,
Tuck Finch, and I proposed
that this may help us
understand Alzheimer's Disease,
which is thought to be a
uniquely human disease,
as we heard previously in Ajit's talk.
And, our ideal relates
to the Glymphatic System,
the system of the brain that's
only recently been discovered
in the last several years.
It's an amazing set of discoveries,
and this Glymphatic System
is involved in removing
metabolic byproducts,
including amyloid beta,
which is involved, of course, as you know,
in Alzheimer's Disease.
And so a lot's being
learned about this system
of how the cerebral spinal
fluid moves through the brain
and picks up various kinds of
pollutants in the brain
and carries them away.
And, most importantly for our hypothesis,
is that this system functions
most effectively during sleep.
So we're proposing that
this is one trade-off,
there're probably others, of evolution
acting to reduce sleep
along the human lineage.
So, I hope I've convinced you that
this evolution perspective is useful
for understanding this
love/hate relationship
that we have with sleep, and I wanna
thank you all for staying wake.
I didn't see anyone sleeping, thank you.
(audience applauding)
And I wanna especially
thank my collaborator
on a lot of this, David Samson.
(dramatic piano music)
- I'm talking about
adaptations to high altitude.
First, let's ask what is high altitude?
We typically define high altitude
as 2500 meters, that
is 8000 feet or higher.
That obviously covers a lot of ground.
Down on the bottom right,
you might be thinking,
"Oh, high altitude and rugged mountaineers
"seeking to climb to the summit
"of Mt Manaslu at 27,000 feet."
Or you may think of athletes
such as the soccer player
from sea level who is playing
at 12,000 feet in Bolivia.
And those are ways in which
many, many people are
exposed to high altitude.
The top two photos describe
another type of exposure to high altitude,
and that is people who have been living,
who are the descendants of populations
that have been resident at high altitude
for thousands of years.
On the right are Andean
Highlander children
who are descended from
the population that has
lived there at high
altitude, in this case,
about 14,000 feet for
something like 14,000 years.
On the left, the Tibetan woman spinning
is the descendant of Tibetan populations
and there have been people living
on the Tibetan plateau
for 20 to 30,000 years.
So, you can see that the
exposure and the actual altitude
varies enormously when we talk about
adaptations to high altitude.
Why is high altitude so interesting?
Well, one of the reasons
it's so interesting
is that there is a unique and very severe
stress, and it's called hypoxia,
less than the usual oxygen level
If we think of ourselves
here in San Diego,
think of taking a lung full of air
and you get a certain number of molecules.
Let's call that 100%.
As you go up in altitude,
barometric pressure falls,
and as we know, the
molecules grow further apart,
and there are fewer
molecules per unit of volume.
By the time we're in
Denver, at 1500 meters,
or about 5100 feet, that
same lung full of air
has only about 80% of
those oxygen molecules.
At's Pike's Peak, at about 14,100 feet,
each lung full of air has only
about 58% of the same molecules.
Now, this is a severe stress,
and it's a stress that's constant.
It doesn't go away with the seasons,
it doesn't go away if
you're rich or you're poor.
So, this makes it a good stress to study.
Now, what is an adaptation?
What does hypoxia have
to do with being a stress
to which we might have to adapt?
Well, we need to get a sufficient number
of oxygen molecules from our
lungs in the ambient air.
We need to exchange those
with our bloodstream.
We need to transport
those oxygen molecules
through the heart, the
cardiovascular system,
and deliver them to our mitochondria
where they are used.
And, our mitochondria must
have those oxygen molecules.
So, what do we do when
faced with a situation
where, let's say there are only 60%
of the usual number of oxygen molecules?
Well, something has to
happen with gas exchange,
gas transport, or gas use,
and that something are adaptations.
I'll use adaptation in a
very general way to refer to
a biological response that
increases survival and
reproduction under a stress.
And adaptations can take place
on a wide range of time scales.
As the X-axis shows, some acclimatizations
can take place in seconds,
hours, days, or months.
We refer to those that are really fast
and are reversible as acclimatizations.
Another type of adaptation occurs
if we grow up under a particular stress.
That's an irreversible
developmental adaptation.
Over the course of generations
and thousands of years,
or hundreds of thousands of years,
natural selection may
result in an increase in
allele frequency of
alleles that are effective
at counteracting the environmental stress.
Let's first look at ourselves.
I'm assuming everyone here is like me,
and we've all been born
and raised at low altitude.
So, we lowlanders, let's
say we go to Pike's Peak,
or we go to Everest Base Camp.
We acclimatize, we acclimatize
at the level of oxygen exchange
by increasing our breathing,
and you can see from this plot that shows
over days at altitude from
before you go to altitude
to up to about three weeks
or a month at altitude,
our ventilation increases enormously.
What does that do?
It means that the number of liters of air
that we're taking in in
a minute is increased.
That's how we get enough oxygen molecules,
or how our bodies are
responding to or acclimatizing
so that we get enough oxygen molecules,
at least at the beginning
of the transport system.
This is an acclimatization that is
sustained for years at high altitude.
After decades, it starts
to fade and become blunted.
We also acclimatize at the
level of gas transport,
or oxygen transport, by hemoglobin.
And the way we do that is,
there is an increase in an erythropoietin
that stimulates the production
of more red blood cells
containing more hemoglobin.
More hemoglobin molecules to carry oxygen.
So again, now we're adapting
at the level of gas transport.
The higher the altitude,
the higher the stress,
the higher the hemoglobin concentration.
This also is an acclimatization response
that lasts indefinitely until
we return to low altitude
and then it is reversed.
At the level of gas use, or oxygen use,
something very puzzling happens
and that is at least
for the first few weeks
at altitude, our gas use as measured
by our basal metabolic rate,
that's the minimum amount
of oxygen that's required
to keep us alive by our heart beating
and breathing and so forth,
that actually increases for
the first couple of weeks at altitude.
And then, by three weeks or four weeks
it has returned to its pre exposure level.
So, those are acclimatizations.
And these are within the
per view of all people.
How is it that we mount
those acclimatizations?
Well, we do so, because we have
an oxygen homeostasis pathway consisting
of genes and proteins and
it's a very lovely pathway.
The first element in the
pathway is the oxygen sensor.
It is a protein that is coated
for by a gene called EGLN1.
Second elements in the
pathway are sub-units
of proteins that are called
hypoxyia inducible factors.
We have three of them,
hypoxia inducible factors,
one, two, and three.
Hypoxia inducible factor
one is called one,
because it has a particular protein that
is coated for by a gene called HIF1.
HIF for hypoxyia inducible factor one A.
HIF2 has a sub-unit coated for by HIF2A,
and the same for HIF3.
These three hypoxia inducible factors
are transcription factors, and they,
once the oxygen sensor senses
that a cell is hypoxic,
these hypoxia inducible factors accumulate
and they induce the transcription
of hundreds of target genes
that increase gas exchange,
increase gas transport,
and modify gas use.
One of the target genes
is the erythropoietin.
Why do we have this oxygen
homeostasis pathway?
Well, we have this oxygen
homeostasis pathway
because we're descended from ancestors
that lived at a wide range of
atmospheric oxygen content.
The red line here shows the 21%.
This is the number that
we all learn in school.
Air contains 21% of oxygen.
But, it hasn't always.
Along the X-axis here,
you'll see millions of years,
and we're showing that until
about 650 million years ago,
the earth's atmosphere was
composed of less than 5% oxygen.
Around 600 million years ago,
multicellular animals evolved.
It was at this time
that HIF1A also evolved.
So, we share this with all of our
multicellular animal
compatriots, if you will.
A little bit later, around
550 million years ago,
vertebrates arose, and HIF2A evolved.
Again, we share this with all
of our fellow vertebrates.
At the time, oxygen
concentration was only about 12%.
Then, we went through some periods
of very high oxygen, low,
and about 200 million
years ago, mammals evolved.
And with the evolution of mammals,
we see the evolution of
our third hypoxia inducible factor one.
So the why question of
why are we able to respond
and acclimatize to high altitudes
is that we are descended from a series
of ancestors that evolve these elements
of our oxygen homeostasis system.
So that implies, then, "Well, then, okay,
"we must all," we being all
seven billion of us humans,
"respond in the same way to
high altitude hypoxic stress."
Let's look at that, and let's ask
whether women like this Tibetan highlander
living in the shadow of Mt. Manaslu,
acclimatize in the same way we do.
Let's look at gas exchange,
and we're comparing here
Tibetan and Andean highlanders.
Let's focus on the area above 3500 meters,
that is, the samples of people
who are under hypoxic stress.
You can see that, in
general, what has happened
is that Tibetan highlanders
in the blue triangles
have retained the acclimatization
response of high breathing.
The Andean highlanders
in general have not.
They have blunted that response.
With respect to gas transport,
the opposite occurs.
Andean highlanders have essentially
retained the acclimatization response,
while Tibetan highlanders
have blunted that response.
What about gas use?
Here's a dissertation project for someone.
We don't have very much information.
The little information that we have
is that both Andean
and Tibetan highlanders
have normal as expected oxygen use.
So, we don't see any evidence
for population differences there.
Well, now, in addition to having
three types of adaptations,
Andean, Tibetan, and lowlander,
we also have to think
about acclimatizations,
developmental adaptations,
and genetic adaptations.
So why do we think this contrast exists?
Well, with genomics and being
able to examine whole genomes,
we've discovered that the
actual oxygen sensored gene, EGLN1,
has a number of variants and
that the variants in EGLN1
that exist in Andean
populations are different
from those that exist
in Tibetan populations
and in turn those are
different from the variants
that exist here at low altitude.
The variants are not fixed, but they are
very different allele frequencies.
So this is one reason
for Andean highlanders
having the particular pattern
of low-ventilation/high gas transport.
Tibetans, on the other hand,
not only have mutations
in the oxygen sensor,
they also have mutations
in the HIF2A element of
hypoxia inducible factor 2.
And these are factors
of Tibetan highlanders
that result in a dampened response
to high altitude hypoxia.
The particular association
that is particularly strong
is that with hemoglobin concentration.
Homozygotes for the Tibetan form of HIF2
have two grams of hemoglobin
less than their compatriots
who have the ancestral,
or low-altitude form of that same gene.
So the reason, then, fr this difference
between Andean and Tibetan highlanders
relates to natural selection
and local adaptation.
We have Andean highlanders
and Tibetan highlanders
who've adapted to the same stress
of high altitude hypoxia,
but on a local level
with different mutations and
mutations at different loci.
Now, what are the
implications for medicine,
whether we're at high altitude or low?
You may be surprised to learn that
something like 30% of
the deaths in the U.S.
Are associated with hypoxia.
They're not caused by hypoxia,
but they're associated with hypoxia.
And now that we understand that we have
distinctive oxygen homeostasis pathways,
genes, molecules, proteins, and responses,
we can now look at those deaths
that are associated with hypoxia
and the diseases that precede them,
and we can ask questions about,
"Well do certain variants in
the oxygen homeostasis pathway
"make us more vulnerable,
or do they change
"the prognosis of a disease
associated with hypoxia?
"And, does this give us
opportunity for developing
"pharmacological interventions?"
And, all of those are in process.
So this is one way where
evolutionary medicine,
looking at our evolutionary
history helps us understand
and come up with new ways of looking at
cause and factors associated with
health and disease in our own population.
Thank you very much.
(dramatic piano music)
(light whooshing)
(ambient shimmering)
(dramatic piano music)